voilà à l'avenir nous referons des
sondages d'opinion pour contrôler si le
style j'aime et modernes que nous avons
essayé de donner au journal télévisé
plaît au public ou s'il faut apporter
des modifications à cette formule
mon rôle s'est borné a donné la première
impulsion maintenant la tâche de tous
les jours va incomber à l'équipe de
raymond marcillac
alors je vous pose une question comme
plus indiscrètes plus fait pourquoi un
autre directeur général monsieur bordas
at il nommé à la tête de cette nouvelle
équipe et raymond marcillac à cause des
qualités d'organisateur et d'animateurs
dont il a fait montre à la tête des
émissions sportives
la pratique du sport lui a pris le coup
d'oeil la rapidité est aussi
l'impartialité de l'arbitré il
retransmettait les matchs d'altitude
athlétisme j'espère que le public sera
content de le voir retransmettre le
match de la vie devient alors si vous le
voulez bien monsieur nous allons faire
descendre raymond marcillac à le faire
apparaître sur cette espèce de tableau
magique qui va ben soir raymond qui va
dorénavant être une des pièces
maîtresses du nouveau journal télévisé
le maire raymond marcillac à vous de
jouer c'est comme à la chasse
je ne vous dis pas bonne chance comme
monsieur peyrefitte vient de le déclarer
le journal télévisé vous appartient à
vous téléspectateurs
c'est à vous de nous dire si nous avons
réussi ou si nous avons échoué
je vous demande cependant nommer ces
quelques jours pour nous juger
définitivement mais en définitive c'est
à vous qu'appartiendra le verdict et
maintenant place au nouveau journal
télévisé
georges de caunes vous êtes maintenant
avant le départ avant un départ assez
curieux une aventure assez curieuse qui
concerne principalement les éditeurs de
la ftf oui je pars je prends le bateau
du 17 juillet à marseille le calédonien
et je pars pour taipei une fois arrivé à
tahiti je pars je passe deux semaines à
tahiti et je pars m'installer pour un an
dans une île déserte
mon projet c'est de refaire du coucher
avec mon chien lui demande de se coucher
il fait une difficulté actuellement de
gens avec mon chien c'est de faire
l'histoire de refaire l'histoire de
robinson crusoé pendant combien de temps
je j'ai signé avec les rts pour une
durée d'un an ça me semble une durée
normale ni trop court mais assez long
quand même pour de cette expérience
et puis une certaine valeur alors vous
partez pratiquement sans dire au départ
avec les seules ressources de la pêche
je pense avec une naïveté considérable
je parlais avec mon chien avec
l'intention d'attraper du poisson parce
que les eaux sont très seuls deux
poissonneuse dans la jante haïti avec
l'intention d'attraper des noix de coco
parce qu'il y a dans les noix de coco de
l'eau qui me permettra de boire et de
faire voir mon chien et avec l'intention
de faire des émissions qui je pense
intéresseront le public de france 1 tous
les soirs à 19h45 vous voyez que pas une
occasion de rappeler la propagande avec
la tension dans l'espoir que les
auditeurs de françois trouveront dans le
témoignage de l'individu seul en face de
lui même peut être une bouffée d'évasion
d'air frais et peut être aussi la
réalisation d'un rêve qu'ils ont tous eu
plus ou moins qu'ils ont peut-être
encore celui de l'abandonner la société
d'aller vivre ailleurs
vous portez en vain son mémento avec du
matériel jamais nommé leader deux
émetteurs de radio qui me permettent
d'être tous les jours en liaison avec
papeete le radier des fps et papé
transmet pas bête retransmet à le chien
une grande importance je pense que le
chien est une grande importance pour les
gens qui aiment les chiens maman chien
est mon ami en skeet pas à paris en
partage devant les mauvais
moment et j'espère que ce seront des
bons moments que je vais offrir dans
l'île déserte la solitude sera moins
difficile pour lui et pour moi puisque
nous serons ensemble
bon voyage en tout cas merci à tous les
jours son antenne et à partir de quand à
partir du 17 septembre mexique
demain matin
cent quarante neuf coureurs représentant
l'élite mondiale du cyclisme
participeront aux classiques paris
roubaix la plus grande de toutes les
classiques
parmi ces 100 49 65 belges et seulement
33 français en droit français dont les
trois qui vous sont présentés maintenant
raymond poulidor robert cazala et
georges chape trois équipiers d'une
formation dont on dit d'ailleurs qu'elle
est numériquement la plus faible alors
vraiment polydor une question revient
immédiatement aux lèvres vous qui vous
venez de connaître un échec parce que
cette équipe est peut-être insuffisante
est ce que vous redoutez que dans paris
roubaix pareille mésaventure vous arrive
encore en mésaventure je ne passe pas
d'ailleurs les courses comme paris
roubaix je pense que l'équipe n'a pas un
grand rôle
car c'est une classique d'un jour chaque
coureur défend sachant ce qui est normal
et c'est pas comme si on a un maillot
jaune à défendre oui c'est un peu le
prototype de course qui vous convient
d'ailleurs parce que c'est la lutte
individuelle la lui touche ou vraiment
on doit donner le meilleur de vous même
et ce que bien franchement vous croyez
qu'il existe une autre course plus
difficile que paris-roubaix plus
difficile je ne pense pas non
paris-roubaix très spécial mais
évidemment il faut il faut marcher le
jour de la course mais il ya une part de
chance qu'ils jouent aussi qui
intervient robert cazala vous croyez
raymond poulidor susceptible cette année
d'un d'amener une victoire à la france
une victoire que la france recherche
depuis louison bobet forestier c'est à
dire depuis plusieurs années b c'est à
dire de mer je l'espère je l'espère bien
mais en cours de saison certains
carrément
va gagner une course une nouvelle course
vous voyez déjà plus loin de paris
roubaix
oui mais vous savez parejo vais pas
avoir beaucoup de chance comme
désherbant total heures il ya il ya un
facteur chance qui joue énormément parce
que
il ya beaucoup d'encre en raison de
chutes et surtout si le temps est
pluvieux ce sera encore plus dangereux
georges chat vous avez été champion du
monde amateur c'est déjà un titre
dans quel état d'esprit abordez vous
votre premier paris roubaix je vienne à
pourvoir pour reprendre mon métier je
vois c'est que 600 autres ambitions non
pas spécialement
avez vous l'impression que c'est une
course qui puisse sourire un jeune par
une tentative audacieuse je ne sais pas
avec une échappée dans les 100 premiers
kilomètres
une quinzaine je sais pas je crois pas
quand même dans ce que les kosovars
position reste on dit dans les pelotons
quand on parle de paris-roubaix
maintenant je sais pas trop quoi c'est
dur c'est dur c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire et bien rendez vous demain
après midi sur la piste de roubaix pour
savoir si un français parmi les 33 qui
prendront le départ succédera au
palmarès aux deux derniers vainqueurs
français louison bobet et jean forestier
damas
ni 149 coureurs représentant l'élite
mondiale du cyclisme participeront aux
classiques paris roubaix la plus grande
de toutes les classiques
parmi ces 100 49 65 belges et seulement
33 français en droit français dont les
trois qui vous sont présentés maintenant
raymond poulidor robert cazala et
georges chape trois équipiers d'une
formation dont on dit d'ailleurs qu'elle
est numériquement la plus faible alors
vraiment polydor une question revient
immédiatement aux lèvres vous qui vous
venez de connaître un échec parce que
cette équipe est peut être insuffisante
est ce que vous redoutez que dans paris
roubaix pareille mésaventure vous arrive
encore en mésaventure je ne pense pas
d'ailleurs une course comme paris
roubaix je pense que l'équipe n'a pas un
grand rôle car c'est une classique d'un
jour chaque coureur défense sachant ce
qui est normal et c'est pas comme si on
a un maillot jaune à défendre oui c'est
un peu le prototype de course qui vous
convient d'ailleurs parce que c'est la
lutte individuelle la lui touche ou
vraiment on doit donner le meilleur de
vous même parce que bien franchement
vous croyez qu'il existe une autre
course plus difficile que paris-roubaix
plus difficile je ne pense pas non
paris-roubaix très spécial mais
évidemment il faut il faut marcher le
jour de la course mais il ya une part de
chance qu'ils jouent aussi qui
intervient robert cazala vous croyez
raymond poulidor susceptible cette année
d'un d'amener une victoire à la france
une victoire que la france recherche
depuis louison bobet forestier c'est à
dire depuis plusieurs années mais c'est
à dire de mer je l'espère je l'espère
bien mais en cours de saison certains
m'a carrément
or à gagner une course et une nouvelle
course à renvoyer déjà plus loin de
paris roubaix
oui mais vous savez paris-roubaix voir
beaucoup de chance comme les airs avant
tout à l'heure il ya il ya un facteur
chance qui joue énormément parce que
il ya beaucoup d'encre en raison des
chutes et surtout si le temps est
pluvieux ce sera encore pilote plus
dangereux georges chat vous avez été
champion du monde amateur c'est déjà un
titre
dans quel état d'esprit abordez vous
votre premier paris roubaix ben je
vienne à pourvoir pour reprendre mon
métier quoi je vais voir ce que c'est
quoi sans autre ambition non pas
spécialement
avez vous l'impression que c'est une
course qui puisse sourire un jeune par
une tentative audacieuse je ne sais pas
avec une échappée dans les 100 premiers
kilomètres
une quinzaine je sais pas je crois pas
quand même dans ce que les kosovo n'a
pas résisté aux questions dit dans les
pelotons quand on parle de paris-roubaix
maintenant je sais pas trop quoi c'est
dur c'est dur c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire et bien rendez vous demain
après midi sur la piste de roubaix pour
savoir si un français parmi les 33 qui
prendront le départ succédera au
palmarès aux deux derniers vainqueurs
français louison bobet et jean forestier
et bien maintenant nous allons terminer
cette édition en entrant en contact avec
eux françois gerbaud et maurice séveno
qui nous attendent sur le sommet de la
tour eiffel vous m'entendez françois
bien je vous entends très bien léon et
si nous avons choisi le sommet de la
tour eiffel c'est pour plusieurs raisons
la première c'est pour offrir à nos amis
qui depuis plusieurs années depuis
plusieurs mois nous suivent
régulièrement
c'est pour leur offrir à notre manière
un cadeau insolite qui est paris à nos
pieds paris-iv minet qui se prépare à
fêter la nuit du réveillon
notre cadeau donc de fin d'année et
aussi si nous sommes monté si haut et à
pied avoir fait quelques ascensions de
quelques 900 marque dans des conditions
extrêmement pénibles car ici au sommet
de la tour il souffle un vent de 120 km
à leur paraphe à l'avant qui vous plaque
où vous éloigne des rambardes où je
m'agrippe pour essayer de vous parler
c'est parce que quelquefois vous avez
peut-être l'impression que le journal
était une sorte de deux numéros une
sorte de comment dirais-je de
prestations d'hommes seuls
or en fait c'est tout un ensemble de
gens qui travaillent à ce journal que
nous vous présentons chaque soir et
c'est un peu en pensant à tous ces gens
que vous ne voyez pas que nous sommes
montés ici nous sommes à effet le 3
c'est à dire le centre des relais
hertziens au sommet de la tour eiffel
parmi ces paraboles qui vous distribue
les images que vous recevez en ce moment
c'est bon que nous voyons sur l'écran
prince je pense que c'est moi en tout
cas je vois un projecteur sur maxi roma
et droite est en tout cas je disais donc
que tous ces gens qui sont ici et que
vous ne voyez pas prince des jours et
parfois des nuits pour capter les
reportages en direct que vous recevez c
est qui vous font revivre des événements
soit tragique soit heureux et qu'ils
sont en tout cas le reflet de la vie
maurice séveno lui est en bas juste au
dessous dans la cabine technique dfl 3
la cabine des relais hertziens et si
vous le voulez bien
après avoir rendu hommage à tous ceux
que vous ne voyez pas et après vous vous
souhaiter un bon réveillon je vais
rejoindre tout de suite maurice evans a
tout de suite
oui comme vous le disait françois
l'instant si nous donnons la pression la
plupart du temps de faire un travail non
l'assaut bruit que vous venez d'entendre
c'est une barre de fer qui vient d'être
bouger par l'un de nos caméraman ça
n'est pas grave
marino honda nous annonçait paris panne
pour le dernier journal non pas du tout
si nous n'allons l'impression de faire
un travail de soliste très souvent il
faut pas oublier que nous avons toujours
un grand orchestre derrière nous et
voici une partie de ce grand orchestre à
près de 300 mètres au dessus de paris
l'install des relais hertziens que vous
voyez maintenant sur votre écran ici les
techniciens qui travaillent de 10 à 15
heures par jour dans un tangage à peu
près incessants au moment où je vous
parle
ça bouge énormément françois girbaud
vous disait que le vent était de 120
kilomètres heure c'est tout à fait vrai
et bien croyez moi le travail qui est
fait ici par les techniciens est un
travail qui est de toute façon à la
hauteur si vous me permettez ce mauvais
jeu de mots mais en tout cas croyez
qu'il est tout à fait utile et même
indispensable pour retransmettre dans
très bonnes conditions les émissions de
télévision et pour ne pas perdre les
bonnes habitudes et bien je vais tout de
même vous donner quelques nouvelles
quelques dépêches de cette fin d'après
midi sachez d'abord quand murs les
izvestia annonce pour 1965 la fin des
privations sans spécifié de quels
privation il s'agit sachez également que
l'europe entière l'europe de l'ouest
connaîtra le nouvel an grâce au carillon
de strasbourg c'est en effet en 12
langues et 12 langues parlées par les 17
pays que constitue le conseil de
l'europe que
le monde l'europe tout au moins
apprendre à la naissance de la nouvelle
année et bien si vous le permettez
maintenant mon cher léon nous allons
trinquer avec françois qui vient de
redescendre les quelques marches pour se
joindre à nous dans cette salle des
relais hertzien nous allons trinquer
avec tous les téléspectateurs à la
nouvelle année bien entendu nous voulons
vous voir allons d'ailleurs nous avons
du champagne il ya une histoire il ya
une histoire merveilleuse de champagne
qui racontait aujourd'hui dans les
dépêches
il ya un propriétaire d'un cabaret de
venise qui a trouvé aujourd'hui dans une
bouteille de champagne dans l'emballage
une bouteille de champagne une photo et
une lettre ainsi libellé j'ai 17 ans
voici ma photo mes amis me disent jolie
et je voudrais me marier que celui qui
ouvrira cette bouteille de champagne
m'écrivent et puis après on verra bien
et si vous le voulez je vais vous donner
le nom et l'adresse de ces jeunes filles
parce que c'est tout de même très
charmant en inde et je crois que nous
avons un ennui elle s'appelle elle
s'appelle elle s'appelle alors vous
m'entendez mais vous ne me voyez mais
que vu les bons sens ça me rappelle un
peu à rien de ta marque à epernay france
quand je rappe je répète marianne
danemark
epernay merci beaucoup maurice thévenot
oui alors nous allons sabler le
champagne sans que vous ayez d'image
mais croyez-moi il sera de toute façon
très bon et nous sembleront à la santé
de vous les eaux et de tous nos
téléspectateurs vous êtes gentil mais a
pas écoutés ne triche pas il faut bien
dire que cette dernière émission sept
dernières éditions aura été le résumé de
tout ce qui nous arrive aux actualités
même voyez-vous absolument pas préparés
croyez le bien
il y aura eu ce petit incident vous
voudrez bien selon l'expression
consacrée
et nous sommes navrés de l'utiliser si
souvent vous voudrez bien s'il vous
plaît ne pas nous en tenir rigueur
et je voudrais aussi avant de vous
quitter de vous retrouver maintenant
l'année prochaine vous dire au nom des
quatres présentateur du journal télévisé
de mes amis de georges de caunes
françois gerbaud maurice eveno et de
votre serviteur de vous dire bonsoir et
merci
le m messieurs notre journal va se
terminer l'année aussi il serait peut
être prudent de vérifier que nous
n'avons rien oublié de vous dire tout au
long de 1962 le nom apparemment le
journal télévisé a été très complet et
vous a vraiment tout dit a encore une
chose je vois veux veux mais à la date
du 1er janvier mais devancé l'actualité
le nous fait pas peur ou plutôt que de
vous dire bonne année bonne santé comme
tout le monde nous avons préféré vous
envoyer quelques cartes
ces cartes de voeux c'est à notre ami
georges hibon nous avons demandé les
dessiner georges vous l'avez demandé
d'imaginer des voeux auxquels on prend
ce pas le 31 décembre
de là nous parler d'un co je trouve que
oui on peut demander ça n'est pas ça
qu'on leur soit on sait ça ah je
comprends que c'est une très bonne idée
venez là moi celle ci nous allons
l'envoyer au ministre des finances
voilà et ça vient ça voyez vous c'est
pour souhaiter de grands voyages de bon
voyage aux téléspectateurs et aussi aux
journalistes du journal télévisé
d'ailleurs il ya une allusion qui vous
concerne directement à juger plus haut
et vahinés révèle idée aussi des là moi
je vais l'envoyer au directeur de la rtf
la cette carte s'adresse plus
particulièrement aux journalistes du
journal télévisé c'est pour leur
souhaiter ce statut dont on parle tant à
le diable jour en ligne augurera cette
statue de la rtf vous seront bien
contents c'est la plus vide à mansle
envoyée au ministre de l'information
j'ai pensé que l'essence mon dieu s'il
pouvait être gratuite arriverait à faire
plaisir aux automobilistes sûrement pour
le ministre des transports et travaux
publics et du tourisme
et enfin enfin c'est le voeu n'est ce
pas qu'on peut souhaiter à tous c'est
souhaiter qu'il n'y ait plus de bombes h
et que l'on connaisse la paix ça je
crois que c'est la meilleure idée
et cette carte nous allons l'envoyer à
tous les chefs d'état du monde mais
je trouve que ça manque de voeux pour le
les téléspectateurs tout simplement la
voix hier à pau plusieurs ministres pour
les chefs d'état voyez pas imaginer
quelque chose pour les téléspectateurs à
m'écouter si on va essayer alors pour
les téléspectateurs il ya d'abord la
poste de télévision entre vous parlez de
riez coller ça dessus tout ça rappellera
que c'est qu'on a le journal ça va
et après après mais accordé permis si
bon réveillon
c'est là au chaud s'il vous plaît